hi everyone I'm Steve Brunton and I'm
going to talk today about modern Koopman
operator theory and how it's changing
what is possible in dynamical systems
and essentially addressing some of the
modern challenges we face in in
data-driven dynamical systems so what
I'm going to talk about I'm going to
break this up in two parts kind of these
different focus areas of what is
challenging in dynamics now and how
human operator theory is starting to
address some of these challenges this is
all joint work with Nathan Coates and
our collaborators Bing Brenton Josh
Proctor Erika Kaiser Bethany lush and
Kathleen champion so this is kind of
work we've been doing for for the last
several years thinking about how we can
use Koopman analysis to start to solve
these data-driven dynamical systems
problems this work has been supported
very generously by DARPA the Army
Research Office the Air Force Office of
Scientific Research and the Air Force
Research Laboratory so it's been great
that there's been a lot of interest and
support to develop these techniques and
we've also been working with
collaborators and colleagues across the
country and across the world to kind of
develop some of these methods so I want
to introduce I want to start off by just
kind of framing some of the key
challenges and open problems in in
data-driven dynamical systems as I see
them and this will frame some of the
progress and some of the things we've
chosen to work on with Koopman operator
theory so here we have a dynamical
system X dot equals f of X here X is the
state of your system this is kind of the
minimal set of variables needed to
describe the evolution of the system and
time F is a function of vector field
that tells you how the system changes at
a given state in time in general this
could be a function of time it could
also have some parameters it could have
some control inputs but I'm just keeping
it simple for now you know we're talking
about these dynamical systems and the
fact that these are nonlinear really are
is kind of the central challenge in this
all okay so I'm just going to walk
through some of these these challenges
as I see them this is not comprehensive
or complete but these are some of the
open problems that have framed our
thinking so probably the one of the
biggest or one of the two biggest
problems is
is usually when we do dynamical systems
we actually start with a dynamical
system you start with x equals f of X
maybe I'm analyzing a physical system
like a pendulum on a cart and so I write
down the Lagrangian I write down the
Euler Lagrange equations and I have X
dot equals f of X I then look at fixed
points and periodic orbits and stability
and so on and so forth but increasingly
for systems of interest we don't
actually have access to these equations
or they might be partially known or
partially unknown so there's no equation
for your brain or for the climate or a
disease spreading across the country
right like there's no governing
fundamental true physics equation that
we can we can rely on so discovering the
equations from data is very important
something Koopman can help with
fundamentally we are looking at
nonlinear dynamical systems so the
theory of linear systems is very well
understood we know a lot about how to
analyze X dot equals a matrix a times X
we look at the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of that matrix and we can
kind of analyze the behavior in terms of
those dynamics but non-linear dynamics
are still very poorly understood and
even kind of an epsilon non-linearity or
even a quadratic non-linearity really
kind of confounds our understanding okay
we don't even know if solutions exist
and are unique for some of these systems
and that's really something Koopmans
gonna help with so i'm a control
theorist i don't just want to model and
understand on linear dynamics i
essentially want to use those models for
estimation and control tasks to
manipulate the behavior of my system so
i think we should be thinking about this
in the context of control
chaos transients intermittent and
uncertain phenomena are still very
challenging so a lot of what we develop
it here are still quite challenging for
chaotic systems or systems with big
intermittent phenomena or non stationary
system so that's very important
challenge and then multi scale physics I
think this is one of the grand challenge
problems of this kind of big data era is
in the past a lot of what we've done has
been really applying analysis and
computations and these kind of dynamical
systems models to yoona scale physics
really now this multiscale kind of
hierarchical physics in space and time
we're starting to get the tools to
tackle this but this is really where we
want to go so all of these these methods
you should be thinking can I apply this
to an actual multi scale problem like
turbulence or climate or disease or
neuroscience okay
there's things I'm leaving off here so
for example I think noise and
stochasticity is a huge one okay so you
know even just computing derivatives
from know what noisy data is still a
pretty big challenge and that's that's
almost like a foundational before you
even get started in dynamics there's
this noise and stochastic city problem
and uncertainty okay but these are the
ones we're gonna talk about in the
context of Koopman for now okay good
so I'm gonna jump into basically just
focusing in on non-linearity that's
really where Koopman analysis has the
most obvious ability to impact is making
nonlinear dynamical systems more
amenable to linear analysis
okay so Koopman analysis is basically
going to be a coordinate transformation
into some special measurement coordinate
where nonlinear systems look linear and
we can use our textbook linear analysis
on those strongly nonlinear systems
okay so Bernhard Koopman back in 1931
introduced this operator perspective for
dynamical systems which really
dramatically changed how how people
think about about dynamical systems and
it's interesting that it's it's been you
know over 80 years since his original
paper and only recently has this started
having a resurgence in the the kind of
modern data-driven dynamical systems
community and and we'll talk about why
it may be took so long but really in in
the in the the decades between Koopman
and now the geometric perspective of
Poincare a has really dominated so
that's that in terms of that state
vector X dot equals f of X and the
geometry of fixed points and periodic
orbits and stable and unstable manifolds
and things like that
what Koopman showed and this was in his
famous 1931 paper in the Proceedings of
the
National Academy of Sciences he showed
that for dynamical systems if you think
about the hilbert space of all possible
measurements you could take of that
system so this is a infinite dimensional
space of all measurements you could take
not just of x but x squared and cosine x
and an arc tan of x and and so on so
this infinite set of measurements you
could take the nonlinear dynamics in
that measurement space look like a big
infinite dimensional linear operator
that evolves those measurements forward
in time okay so what Koopman showed is
that you can essentially lift your
non-linear dynamics in a state space
representation into this infinite
dimensional measurement representation
and your non-linear dynamics here become
linear dynamics up here and you're
trading complexity so it's very hard now
to work with this infinite dimensional
linear operator so we're trying to find
approximations and embeddings and
representations okay so that's where
it's going now you know but back in 1931
people weren't thinking of big data and
big computations and machine learning
but now we're so focused on data science
and so his perspective in terms of
measurement equations actually fits very
nicely so measurements is just a fancy
word for data or vice versa this Koopman
theory now is very relevant as we have
increasing amounts of data that we can
fit these approximately big linear
models to okay interestingly when
Koopmans paper came out it was actually
central a central kind of missing piece
in the proof of the ergodic theorem by
john von Neumann and Georg Birkhoff kind
of independently proved this this
ergodic theorem and they used Koopmans
operator theory as this missing piece in
in in their theories okay so actually in
the 30s this was a very famous paper
extremely pivotal and influential in the
ergodic theorem which was one of the
most important milestones and dynamical
systems but then kind of the modern
perspective really didn't come into play
until until much later and there's a
great perspective in PNAS on the ergodic
theorem statistical mechanics and
this history of Koopman and von Neumann
and birkhoff's so very interesting paper
I recommend you read it and so really
this Koopman operator perspective didn't
really come back into the mainstream
focus for decades and largely it's
responsible or sorry largely egor
message and his collaborators work is
responsible for bringing this back into
the mainstream and the spotlight so this
is a famous paper 2005 paper and there's
some earlier kind of you know 1999 and
2004 up until now we're eager and
collaborators really brought this
Koopman perspective back into data
driven dynamical systems and showed that
this linear operator representation of
your nonlinear system can be very useful
if you compute its eigenvalues and
eigenvectors you get a spectral
decomposition that you can use for
analysis prediction and control okay so
very useful now in this in this kind of
modern data-driven
error --air right now that we have fast
computers tons of data this Koopman
perspective is becoming very popular and
here's a cool kind of snippet from this
paper where you can actually see this
Koopman mode decomposition in terms of
eigen values eigen functions initial
conditions and here is what's known as a
continuous eigen value spectrum so
that's kind of something we'll talk
about later for for interesting mixing
and chaotic systems and so you know I
mentioned that the geometric perspective
of Poincare a has really dominated this
is this is a you know a state space
model in terms of some nonlinear
equations you can integrate trajectories
through these equations and you can get
an update and you can watch particles
and trajectories go through these
dynamics and you can look at what are
the separate receives what are the
invariant manifolds or the attractors
that's what we've been doing for decades
it's very useful what the Koopman
operator perspective does is instead it
thinks about measurements of the system
G so G could be any measurement of X in
this Hilbert space of measurements it
could be cosine of the first component
of x times the third can
and squared minus the square root of x2
okay it could be this arbitrarily
complex function of my state and so G
lives in an infinite dimensional hilbert
space and if I picked a basis you could
kind of write this down as an infinite
vector of coefficients and in that basis
maybe in a Taylor series or a Fourier
basis and what the Koopman operator this
K operator does is it advances those
measurements forward one time step so it
basically takes that state X it advances
at one time step and then it remesh is
the system at that next time step so the
Koopman operator advances all possible
measurement functions one time step in
the future and so what people are trying
to do now is find finite dimensional
approximations of this Koopman operator
and if you can find a finite dimensional
approximation that's a matrix it's a
linear matrix that advances measurements
forward in time that can be very useful
you can compute the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and and get future
prediction and estimation and control
but finding a closed finite dimensional
approximation of this infinite
dimensional operator is very challenging
and it's been the focus of intense
research efforts over the last decade
okay and so I'm going to kind of give
away some of the story what we know now
is that we're trying to identify
eigenfunctions of this Koopman operator
because eigenfunctions of this Koopman
operator are these special eigen
measurements that if i measure my
non-linear system in those exact
measurements those measurements would
behave linearly in time they'd have
exponential behavior or oscillatory
pure-tone sine and cosine behavior and
you know linear dynamics so that's what
we're trying to find our I can function
of this and if I found a bunch of eigen
functions I could span a Koopman
invariant subspace and if I restricted
my Koopman operator to that subspace I
would get a matrix a finite dimensional
matrix so for example if I found three
Koopman eigenfunctions I would get a
three by three matrix that evolves those
measurements linearly forward in time
very useful okay good
so very simple example to show you that
this works and you can read more about
this and just play
with us in MATLAB if I have this simple
nonlinear dynamical system in two state
variables x1 and x2 notice that the
first variable is decoupled so there's
no x2 dependence and this is purely
linear the second variable is nonlinear
and if lambda is a fast eigenvalue if
it's more stable than me a more negative
real part then x2 will very rapidly
equal x1 squared and so you can see this
slow manifold in red here and my initial
conditions rapidly adhere on to this
manifold and slowly go down to the
origin if both of these are stable and
so what Koopman theory says is if I take
if I enrich my measurement space if I
don't just measure x1 and x2 but I also
measure x1 squared a nonlinear
measurement in this measurement space
these three measurements I can write my
nonlinear system as an actual linear
dynamical 3x3 system so this is like an
a matrix it's a real linear system in
terms of these nonlinear measurements
let's just verify that this works so y1
is x1 x1 dot equals mu times x1 good y2
is x2 so y 2 dot is lambda X 2 that's
lambda X 2 minus lambda X 1 squared
which is minus lambda y3 good so that
nonlinear equation became linear by
adding y3 and here's the kind of the
crux what's y3 dots
well y3 is x1 squared so the derivative
is 2 x1 x1 dots which is 2 X 1 mu X 1 2
mu X 1 squared so this derivative is 2
mu x1 squared and so even that equation
is linear in terms of this y3 variable
the derivative of Y 3 is just 2 mu times
y 3 and so here's a MATLAB simulation of
this 3x3 linear system and you can see
that if I project on to the x1 and x2
variables I recover this slow manifold
behavior so this is a super simple
example showing that nonlinear dynamical
systems can be embedded in a linear
framework with the right measurements of
the system this is a really simple toy
example that works ok and that's what
we're trying to do is find these good
measurements wife or for other dynamical
systems that give these linear
representation
because I can predict the future in this
system as far in the future as I like
without having to do some nonlinear
integration okay and then you can look
at the eigen values and eigenvectors of
this matrix to find your Koopman eigen
functions okay so that's a case that
works this is a case that doesn't work x
dot equals x squared I mean it should be
even simpler but if I look at X dot
equals x squared so I think a lot of us
know what the behavior of this dynamical
system is I always ask my students what
what characterizes this dynamical system
and I like to joke that you can't say
this in an airport because this thing
has finite time blow-up okay so this
differential equation will go to
infinity in a finite amount of time
which is kind of nasty so let's try the
same thing we're gonna build this
nonlinear measurement and augment our
measurements with an x squared so if I
take the derivative of Y 1 or X Y 1 dot
does in fact equal Y 2 that's good but
the derivative of Y 2 is 2 X X dot which
is 2 x times x squared which is 2 X
cubed and so it's not in the span it's
not a linear combination of these
functions so if I take the derivative of
Y 2 I get an X cubed which is not in my
measurement space so I need to add an X
cubed but then when I take the
derivative of my X cubed I get 3 X dot x
squared which is 3 X to the fourth so
now I need to add an X to the fourth and
the basic idea is that this never closes
I always need higher and higher order
polynomials and so I would eventually
need infinitely many an infinite Taylor
expansion to represent the solution of
of this this system so this doesn't
close I don't get a finite dimensional
model if I increase the order I do get
closer and closer to this white line
which is the true finite blow-up
solution but it's pretty slow
convergence and it doesn't work very
well so one takeaway is just arbitrarily
choosing a Taylor series or a Fourier
basis for your Hilbert space probably
isn't going to work these are going to
be very specialized bases where you get
finite dimensional representations of
Koopman and in fact it's based on
eigenfunctions so the right
representation
our eigen functions of the Koopman
operator and polynomials might be a bad
basis to represent these dynamics in so
what you can do and I remember asking
Clancy Raleigh this once we were waiting
for a bus at a workshop and I asked him
you know I told him about this
disclosure issue and I think he wrote
down the solution fee of X equals e to
the minus 1 over X and this happens to
be one of those magic measurement
functions one of these eigenfunctions of
Koopman that if you just measured your
system in this fie coordinate fie dot
equals fie so it's linear dynamics and
fie but notice that it's not just a
simple polynomial expression it's not
easily representable in a finite Taylor
series okay and so this is so there are
these special coordinates but you need
to be able to find these for much more
complicated systems like turbulence or
the brain so the that's the burning
question how do you find these
eigenfunctions how do you represent
these eigenfunctions for more and more
complex dynamical systems okay so
Koopman eigenfunctions define these
invariant subspaces we start with
nonlinear dynamics X dot equals f of X
we want to find fee of X these special
coordinates fee so that they're linear
dynamics in these measurement
coordinates so this is just a linear
dynamical system and so what we can do
is we can take the chain rule of the
derivative of V with respect DDT of V of
X and we get the gradient of V dotted
with the time derivative of X so grad
feed times X dot and X dot is just f of
X so this is what the time derivative
the chain rule of my time derivative is
grad feed dotted with my dynamics F and
that has to equal lambda fie okay so
that equals lambda fee that is a partial
differential equation generator for
Koopman eigenfunctions so any Koopman
eigenfunction has to be a solution of
this PDE at least in for the smooth
eigenfunctions in continuous-time so I
moved to continuous-time dynamics
because that's easier for now there's
also a more general Koopman theory for
discrete-time finite time updates but a
smooth continuous eigenfunction
for these smooth dynamics has to satisfy
this equation and so now if we revisit
this X dot equals x squared what I can
do is I can write down a Laurent series
for fee I can I can allow it to have a
forward Taylor expansion in terms of
powers of X x x squared X cubed x to the
fourth and also a negative kind of this
inverse power series 1 over X 1 over x
squared 1 over X cubed that's called a
Laurent series and I can take that
Laurent series with arbitrary
coefficients plug it into this PDE and
when I solve for what those coefficients
have to be for this to be true what pops
out is e to the minus 1 over X so for
low dimensional dynamical systems where
you know f of X you can actually solve
for eigen functions analytically using
taylor or Laurent series with this
generator and now this is actually a
homework problem in my math class so I
don't know if you can see here but
basically the eigenfunction they've
solved for it on the whiteboard in my
office okay so we know how to do this
now but what do you do in practice when
you don't have like a really simple x
dot equals x squared in one variable
where you know the dynamics okay so
that's kind of a very very simple toy
problem we want to be taking the
data-driven perspective and doing
Koopman on real problems of interest
like neuroscience disease modeling
turbulence control so what do we do in
practice when we can't solve a Laurent
series or just write down an
eigenfunction so people look at the
dynamic mode decomposition this is one
of the workhorse algorithms to
approximate the Koopman operator and so
if I had a movie of vortex shedding past
a cylinder so this is a fluid flow past
a cylinder here are snapshots in that
movie as it evolves in time so you get
this periodic von Karman vortex shedding
if I took all of that data what I can do
is I can find the best fit linear
operator that advances that data forward
in time and that should be related to
the Koopman operator so this was a
connection that clancy rally igor and
their collaborators made in this kind of
landmark jfm paper in 2009 where they
connected this dynamic mode
decomposition algorithm
this algorithm was developed by Peter
Schmitz earlier they applied this
algorithm in and connected it to Koopman
operator so the result of DMD so what
DMD does is essentially it takes this
data it stacks it into big data matrices
where each column is an entire state
vector stacked into a tall column vector
so x1 is my all of my measurements at
time 1 x2 is all of my measurements at
time 2 and so on so you build X and then
X prime is my matrix shifted one time
step in the future so these are my
measurements and these are my measured
measurements one time step in the future
and what DMD does is it tries to find
this best fit linear operator a that
advances X into X Prime
so you basically write down the equation
X prime equals a times X and you try to
solve for a using pseudo inverse and
regression you try to solve for a and
DMD is a little fancier than this
because this a matrix would be gigantic
maybe million by million or billion by
billion so essentially now what I'm
trying to what what we try to do is find
the dominant eigen values and eigen
vectors of a and a is starting to look a
lot like the Koopman operator the
Koopman operator advances measurements
forward in time linearly and so even
though this is a nonlinear dynamical
system we're trying to find the best fit
linear operator to the advances of those
measurements and then we're trying to
look for eigen vectors eigenfunctions
and eigenvalues of this and it works
remarkably well for data that is
periodic or quasi periodic so this
vortex shedding is periodic d-md works
great it's not as good for transients
and intermittent phenomena so you need a
little bit fancier version of the
regression and data but we'll talk about
that later ok and so the DMD is kind of
like this this hybrid marriage of
principal components analysis in space
so you pull up the dominant spatial
coherent structures and then the Fourier
transform in time so you want to find
dominant modes that are coherently
oscillating in space that are coherent
in space and have a fixed oscillation or
decay in time ok so that's what the DMT
algorithm does and again this this 2009
pen paper connected the the results of
DMD algorithm with this Koopman theory
this infinite dimensional linear
operator so very important and since
then DMD has become one of the workhorse
algorithms for Kookmin okay so the DMD
algorithm itself was originally
introduced in the fluids dynamic
dynamics community by Peter Schmidt in
fact there's this ApS abstract from 2008
by Schmidt ancestor hen where they
presented this and this is essentially a
very useful tool for extracting these
these coherent structures that that have
simple time dynamics as this nonlinear
system involves and that's exactly what
we want our equipment eigenfunctions to
do we want to find these magic special
measurements these this magic mixture of
measurements that if I measure my system
in exactly that way I get pure tone sine
waves or Exponential's these kind of
linear dynamics and it turns out that's
what dynamic mode decomposition does and
that connection again was made by this
in this great paper by Clancy Igor
servin Phil and Dan where they
essentially showed that the Koopman
operator is connected to this dynamic
mode decomposition and they applied it
to analyze this really rich flow which
is a jet in a cross flow and to pull out
these coherent modes that oscillate at a
fixed frequency in time since then
there's been a lot of great work kind of
shoring up this connection and
developing this connection and a lot of
it's been done in fluid dynamics that's
kind of one of these hot areas or
Koopman and data different methods are
really coming together so there's a
great paper by Shervin Bagheri where he
analyzes the Koopman mode decomposition
of the flow past a cylinder which is a
very nice kind of closed solution for
one of our canonical benchmark problems
and fluids this is a great paper I
highly recommend you read it here are
some cool fluid modes on the writes and
then there's also been a really nice
connection between Koopman operator
theory and the resolve n't analysis the
resolve n't mode decomposition which is
a very powerful technique in fluid
dynamics to understand the sensitivity
of flows and which structures will be
amplified in which structures
decay in time so there's this great
paper by Sharma message and McKeon
really really nice connection again to
flow structures resolve an analysis and
Koopman okay so this is exploding the
interest in Koopman is really really
growing we have efficient algorithms now
to start approximating it we have rich
data from physical systems and the
Koopman operator is giving us this
ability to represent these nonlinear
systems in a linear framework under
certain conditions
okay so we're gonna talk a lot more
about Koopman we're gonna talk about how
you can use it for control we're gonna
find how do you represent Koopman
eigenfunctions and discover them what
are these non-linear measurements of
your system we're gonna talk about
chaotic systems and systems with what
are known as continuous eigenvalue
spectra and we're also going to talk
about multi scale systems
okay so there's gonna be multiple parts
this is going to build up but I hope
you're kind of interested and excited
about Koopman theory as a possible
framework to start handling strong
non-linearity with data okay thank you